Speaker 1: All right, let's let's keep going
on a bunch of different policy things that
I've been wanting to talk about, and I'm glad to
have the opportunity to talk about today. Let's
talk a little bit about Title 42. Title 42 is
something that was created under Donald Trump CDC
to very quickly remove people from the United
States without actually going through the
deportation process under the guise of public
health. And numerous legal opinions are that it's
being misused or it shouldn't even exist in the in
the first place. But the Joe Biden administration
is using Title 42 to remove people as well. And we
should be. If we were critical of Trump using it,
we should be critical of Joe Biden using it as
well. So let's look at a relatively recent time
article about this. Biden is expelling
immigrants migrants on COVID 19 grounds,
but health experts say that's all wrong.
Despite sharp criticism from top officials
and allies within the Democratic Party,
President Biden is continuing to expel
hundreds of thousands of migrants arriving at
the US-Mexico border using a specialized public
health order that allows officials to circumvent
the normal trappings of immigration procedure,
including asylum interviews. The Biden
administration is defending its controversial
use of the order, called Title 42, arguing in
court that summary expulsions are quote necessary
due to the ongoing risks of transmission and
spread of COVID 19. But a growing cacophony
of top public health experts are calling foul.
There's no evidence that a policy allowing for
mass expulsions prevents the spread of COVID, they
argue, and it may in fact have the opposite effect
by rounding up and detaining hundreds of thousands
of migrants in large groups. CBP, which does not
offer COVID testing for migrants, may actually be
stoking the transmission of the disease. Migrants
often spend days and weeks in crowded facilities
before they are transported and expelled.
The title 42 order fuels the pandemic, says Julia
Koehler, assistant professor of pediatrics. It
does not promote public health. It is opposing
public health. Top Biden administration officials
also appear to be distancing themselves from
the policy. Alejandro Mayorkas said Title 42
quote is not an immigration policy that we in
this administration would embrace, but we view
it as a public health imperative as the CDC has so
ordered. Remember, Title 42 was passed by the CDC
under Trump? I'm sorry. No title 42 was passed
in 1944 as part of the Public Health Service Act,
but it was used by Trump to expel people
without going through the full process of
requesting asylum. Getting that asylum interview
if it's rejected going through a deportation, it's
basically basically like a sort of do not pass,
go do not collect $200, just a direct expulsion.
Under the order, the CDC can temporarily suspend
the introduction of persons into the U.S.
when the CDC director determines the existence
of a communicable disease in a foreign country
or places or place creates a serious danger of
the introduction of disease in the U.S.. The order
has never been used this way before, nor was it
intended as an immigration tool in April of 2020,
he wrote. Stanford Law Professor Lucas Guttentag
wrote Never before, and over 75 years has it
been used as a substitute or mechanism for
regulating admission under the immigration
laws. This is complicated by the reality that one
can you have to read between the lines, although
it's pretty obvious that this was being used by
Trump as a way to enforce his immigration policy
rather than an actual public health measure. And
part of the way we know it is that some of the
reading between the lines is obvious because
Trump didn't really take the virus seriously
at the same time that he was not talking about
masking, pushing back against closures, praising
Ron DeSantis for opening Florida early for I think
it was wrestling and UFC or whatever the case was.
Trump was using Title 42 to justify direct
expulsions, circumventing the actual asylum
and deportation process on the basis of
public health. So it's very transparent that
Donald Trump was was using this without
actually caring about the public health
piece and just saying, Hey, here's a great
way to get people directly out of the country.
Unfortunately, the Biden administration has been
doing the exact same thing. I think that there
are sort of two issues here. Does it work to stop
the spread of COVID? And is it morally the right
thing to do? I think the answer is no on both. In
terms of does it help stop the spread of COVID,
as many health experts have weighed in and
including the ones I just quoted, it doesn't
seem to you are. Even though the premise is direct
and rapid expulsion, it still takes weeks, if not
months. And during that time, folks are crowded
together without being tested for COVID. You may
actually be spreading COVID by using this policy.
That's number one. Number two. What about morally?
I think it doesn't pass the moral
test either. We are. We should
actually adjudicate asylum requests, et cetera,
in the proper normal channels, period. And
while we were critical of the Trump
administration for doing this,
we must be critical of the Biden administration
for doing it. I think it's wrong. Either way,
I don't care if it's a Democrat or a Republican
in the White House. If you disagree with me,
if you think it's OK to be using Title 42
on this basis, then I want to hear from you